foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining my talk today I hope
you guys brought along your shovel since
we're going to be talking about digging
a pit of success over the next 15
minutes or so I'm going to talk about a
framework that we developed at our
Organization for developing a pit of
success
um and so let me talk a little bit about
me before I dive into that
so my name is Aaron Chaffetz I work for
a federal agency called usaid as an
economist and I work in the office of
HIV AIDS our work in the office of HIV
AIDS feeds into a larger interagency
effort known as pepfar the president's
emergency plan for AIDS relief
FR was started in 2004 with the goal of
ending the global HIV epidemic and we
work in an interagency fashion uh with a
host of other agencies like CDC
Department of Defense and Peace Corps
so uh one of the success factors one of
the factors that has made pepfar so
successful is the Reliance and the push
to collect measurement and evaluation
data across the world
so what does that data look like we're
collecting data on HIV status treatment
status and prevention indicators upwards
of maybe 30 different indicators
collected at 30 000 Health Facilities
all across the globe
this data also is coming in each quarter
to us so as you can imagine this adds up
very quickly and we are swimming in data
what makes this even more challenging is
when you don't have the right tools for
the job
so when I started in the office of HIV
AIDS back in 2015 the primary means of
doing analysis was Excel
Excel is great and there's you know
clearly there are useful you uh uses for
it
um but when you're working with data
that come in so frequently and are so
large it's probably not the right tool
for the job
and at that point you kind of have to
recognize that there are better things
out there much like R and so that's uh
when I started in 2016 started realizing
that there was a use case here for using
R I had been using stata as an economist
but even stata stats package didn't
quite cut it in terms of the scale of
the data we were working with
and
um I got really excited about R and
really spent a long time learning this
and tried then to convince other people
and our organization that R was a great
path forward and we needed to to learn
it
problem though you know our has a steep
learning curve and so trying to convince
other people to learn ours much like
telling them just go out and run a
marathon right
it's not easy to do especially when you
don't have a training plan in place
and so after a few unsuccessful years of
proselytizing are just talking about it
what I realized our organization needed
was a pit of success we needed something
that users didn't have to go it alone
when they were learning new skill like r
problem I think in terms of this idea of
success is we often frame it as one of
climbing a mountain right we have to
fight this uphill battle and only when
we have summited this mountain after all
this work we have achieved something
the idea though of a pit of success is
flipping that on its head it's saying
why can't we create an infrastructure so
that in order to succeed it's as easy as
falling into that pit
we've uh and in order to do so we kind
of lay out the guide rails and the
framework uh to make this easy for other
people to do
this is by no means A New Concept or one
that I came up with Hadley was talking
about it way back in 2016 uh in relation
to the Tidy verse and the Tidy verse
definitely was the primary pit of
success for me in learning R and I think
this framework also applies to an
organization
problem is if Hadley's talking about it
why aren't we all already doing this
already and I think there are definitely
some clear barriers in the way of doing
this obviously it's resource intensive
um to set up this pit you need people to
kind of shine that light to show you
show others the path to move this
forward
and it's time intensive both for those
people who are leading the way and for
new people to come on and learn the
skill and then lastly as as part of the
government our hiring practices are just
definitely not as Nimble as the private
sector and our data Stacks are a little
slower to innovate
so I I want to talk about three ways in
which we were able to dig this pit of
success at organization the first the
primary means of doing so was developing
packages to create that infrastructure
then uh creating buy-in at multiple
levels and then lastly fostering
community of support for our users
so starting things off I think the
foundations of of this uh pit of success
were through packages
our work in pepfar we as I mentioned
earlier have lots and lots of data
measurement and valuation data that's
coming in every quarter and this is a
good means to automate something and R
is a great tool for that right so if we
have this data that's similar in coming
in we can start writing scripts uh that
we can automate oh and those scripts as
we get more comfortable we can turn into
functions so that those functions are
useful to you but there also can be
useful to others and slowly started
developing packages uh initially by
myself but I saw that this is a means to
help others enter the field and learn R
so as I became more proficient in R and
we started bringing on more people who
learned R and we had more expertise
there we're able to grow out this
infrastructure to allow new people to
enter more easily so we've developed
over time a ton of different packages
whether they are around solving a
problem for a particular project that we
have to repeat were there more General
utility functions so that people don't
have to recreate the wheel every time
they encounter a problem
so an example of this is one of our
utility packages called glamor where we
do something as simple as setting up a
folder structure right doing this
manually is very easy to do but when
you're talking about having to repeat
this process across lots and lots of
different projects and doing this across
lots of users having something that
allows you to just fall into that pit of
success is important and we do this
through a lot of different ways so like
loading Secrets securely storing and
loading secrets to make it easy for
people to have all their credentials in
one place and to make sure that they're
not posting this to GitHub uh and and
posting their credentials
so packages packages really founded the
foundation of this infrastructure
because they created reproducibility for
our work and consistency across all of
our our our users
and more importantly this created an
approachable way for new users to come
on without having to know the full our
ecosystem but they had tools that were
specific to our workflows that they
could use and take advantage of
so while we have those packages
we didn't really have the buy-in we
didn't have people clamoring to be at
the table to use R and where we started
to be able to turn things around was
really convincing leadership that R was
the the right direction to go
leadership is really critical because
they're the ones who are ultimately
creating that trade-off structure
telling analysts whether they should be
focusing their attention on training
versus having to turn around products
right because there's always that need
for those concrete products
um so that they can create that
um that influence uh both in the
workforce and as they're hiring new
staff on can see this as a marker when
they're looking at CVS uh in in order to
bring that on and the way we were able
to lure in our leadership was through
concrete products we were able to uh and
specifically around visualizations we're
able to build off ggplot by creating our
own package glitter that used our own
themes and colors uh that allowed us to
quickly and efficiently create high
quality products that our leadership
could use to understand where where our
progress was at and use these as
communication pieces and they wanted to
see more and more of these more quickly
we also had to convince our colleagues
that R is a worthwhile investment right
and so I think it's it's clear
automation makes a ton of sense to all
of us in this room but there is that
learning curve and so we needed to
convince our colleagues that that
upfront investment cost uh is worthwhile
spending anywhere from two hours to two
weeks to invest that process so then in
a year when you're re-running all of
these things it only takes seconds to
run those analyzes as opposed to having
to do that comfort in a point-and-click
world where yes it's easy to do that 40
you spend 40 minutes on it instead of
two weeks but you have to spend that 40
minutes every single time that you're
doing this
and so the way we were able to influence
change for our colleagues was to curate
support uh to their different workflows
and uh intervene in specific instances
so maybe it was working with a colleague
to show them how to set up and work with
them to support an API to bring their
data in without having to do a manual
download of data or maybe it was showing
them how to create calculations before
they moved their data into Tableau or
maybe they felt comfortable in the
point-and-click world for all of their
munging but then wanted to have a high
quality product using R for the
visualization side
so it's great we started to have some
buy-in from our users but we needed then
this last piece of community we needed
to support them in some way and I think
everybody here is familiar as you've
started r or some new programming
language there's lots of resources out
there and it's easy to be inundated and
overwhelmed by everything and not sure
where you should start learning and so
we realized early on that we needed to
curate a uh approach for them a path
that they could move forward so that
they knew what direction to go and what
was applicable for our work
so as a result we created a community of
practice in our office called core which
is freely founded on the ideas of being
able to share our workflows and best
practices between inexperienced users
and the ones who had a lot more
experience and as we developed more and
more our users we could do things like
having one-on-one mentorship that we had
people who had been around and knew what
was going on we were able to develop
classroom-like settings to have more
people able to kind of know the 101s of
R setting up a slack channel was really
important as well because it created a
form that people could feel like they
could ask questions very easily and
other people could share new things that
they'd learn
and it didn't have to be a one-way
Street like a classroom setting and then
lastly just kind of setting up you know
infrequent like makeover challenges so
people became more familiar with ggplot
so here's kind of an example of how we
tailored our approach in the classroom
setting so uh myself and other
colleagues set up uh set up a 12-part
series that's based on our for data
science the core principles from R for
data science are there and many of these
chapters are almost copied verbatim but
the difference though is we tailored the
data to what our analysts were familiar
with we used our pepfar data so that an
analyst understood the fund could could
focus on the fundamentals of rather than
having to worry about new data we also
tailored all the examples to things that
worked in our workflow so that they
understood the data they understood
these workflows and could go from the
classroom-like setting to apply it the
very next day in their work which was
quite successful
so setting up this pit of success was
something that just didn't happen
overnight and did take a lot of time and
it's something that we have still been
continuing to do and over the last few
years we have drastically or drastically
increased our user base but I think
what's important is not just the number
of users we have but the work we've been
able to produce we've been able to
increase our efficiency and do more and
higher quality work as a result of more
of an emphasis in r
I I think this model of kind of building
a success and creating an infrastructure
for others in your organization is
really important and I'm happy to be a
resource for anybody uh who's trying
feels like you are that n of one at your
organization and wanting to set this up
my email here and it's in the next slide
as well and then I have some additional
resources that are posted on the slide
and are also on the conference website
as well
so with that I'll end and I wish any of
you who are willing to take on this
challenge the best of luck in digging a
pit of success for your organization
foreign
[Music]